[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello,
I'm Timothy Jordan,
and welcome to The
Developer Show.
I'm standing here with Kathy
Pham who has a very long title.
I'm going to get it right.
It's Health Data Adviser
and Product Manager
at the US Digital Service.
Welcome to the show.
KATHY PHAM: Thank you.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Let's talk
about the US Digital Service,
and let's do it as engineers do.
What's the problem statement?
KATHY PHAM: So the
problem statement
is to solve the technology
problems that face
the federal government today.
It's all revolved
around thinking of a way
to use technology, or
changing the technology that's
in place, to make services
better for the American people.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
The way I've heard
you describe it before and,
sort of, seen it online
is it's like a startup
within the government.
KATHY PHAM: Yep.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And
it's such a cool idea.
KATHY PHAM: It's amazing.
It's been known as the
President's tech startup,
so it's great that we had
the backing of the President.
And it's very much a startup
inside the government.
We've had to build our
entire hiring pipeline,
figure out our
mission, figure out
what projects we're going
to work on, prioritize.
And yeah, it's very much
a little tech startup,
just like you'd have out
here in the Bay Area,
inside government.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: If
you achieve everything
you want to over the
next, say, two years,
how does the government look
different for everyday people?
KATHY PHAM: It shouldn't
matter to you that we're
25 different agencies.
You should just have a
seamless, awesome experience.
What that would mean is that
you have delightful experiences
when you want to bring a
family member into the US.
It is easy to find information,
and you can figure out really
quickly if you were to help
a sibling or a child figure
out what university in your
area and what field of study
to go to so that they have
the best chance of success.
And it means that
our vets can get
the care they need
when they need it,
and they're not waiting
two years to get basic care
or to get mental health help
or to get any of the services
that they absolutely deserve.
And some of that is much
bigger than a tech problem.
Some of it's underlying,
other underlying issues,
but we'll fix what we can at the
tech level to get them there.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I
read your Medium post,
and I was really touched
about your relationship
with your brother
and your mother
and the United
States of America.
And I wanted to ask you, how did
all those things come together
at just the right time to
drive you into this service?
KATHY PHAM: I worked on Google
Health for a little while.
I built data warehouses for
hospitals, and did this work,
and still was enjoying
my time, and was
kind of going
along in my career,
didn't really know
where that would go,
and got a call from
Mikey Dickerson one day.
He was one of the
integral people
in the healthcare.gov
team that turned
around the
healthcare.gov website
when it was basically
unusable back in 2013.
It was all over the news.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I remember that.
KATHY PHAM: And
it became stable.
And so he gave me a
call and was like,
I need someone who knows
health care and data.
Can you come help?
And here I am today,
taking everything
that I've accumulated,
whether it's
the experience I saw from
my mom, the experience I had
in computer science and software
engineering, the empathy
that I have for my little
brother, all of that
has really contributed to this
role here in the United States
Federal Government,
which is, like,
the biggest public service
project you can possibly do.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: If you'd like to
learn more about the US Digital
Service, check out their website
and the Medium publication,
both linked below.
Is there anything
else that they should
do if they want to get,
say, even more involved?
KATHY PHAM: Yes.
So one way to get involved
is to apply directly
at the whitehouse.gov/usds
or 18f.gov,
or look into the Presidential
Innovation Fellows program,
where we bring some of the best
entrepreneurs in the country
into government
to solve problems.
Or join a local government,
look into Code for America
where Fellows are deployed
across the country
to solve their
local governments.
Or better yet, if you
want to keep your day job,
contribute to any of
the open source projects
that we have because
that's a thing now.
We have our code out
on GitHub for many
of the different projects.
You can go and contribute
to that code base
and have your code become
part of the federal government
and contribute to
making America better.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Awesome.
Thanks for joining
me today, Kathy.
KATHY PHAM: Yeah, thank you.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And
don't forget to check out
all the links below.
[MUSIC PLAYING]